hello believe nation I made the mentor
me series to try to hang around people
who have done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little more time
with them some of their mindsets
attitudes beliefs way of thinking seep
into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
going to learn from Bob Proctor on how
to change your paradigm mentor me Bob
and as always as Bob is talking if he
says something that really resonates
with you please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
Oh
when you're going ahead the only thing
you can measure is what you're giving up
what about what's coming you know it's
coming what you want but you've got to
be able to pay the price you gotta have
guts if you've got guts you don't
deserve it the opposite of courage in
our society is not cowardice it is
conformity and there you have the
trouble today
it's conformity people acting like
everyone else without knowing why
without knowing where they're going
it was like a bucket of ice water got
dumped on my head and I started really
wondering but is there something bigger
is there something more
and then Bob kept saying in a way that
only he can say what do you want what
you really want and he said don't think
about what you think you can have he
said most people are extras in their own
movie what do you really want if you
believed you could have absolutely
anything do whatever you want to be
whoever you wanted what do you want
regardless of the intellectual or
physical abuse you're subjected to no
one can cause you to think something you
don't want to think you've got absolute
control over your thinking no one can
change you if you don't want to be
changed
[Music]
life is very short you're not here for a
long time
Noorie here for a short time every one
of us are hard-wired to do something
phenomenal with our life we're God's
highest form of creation we should start
[Music]
I'm going to share some information with
you that it could change the direction
of your life like night and day and when
I say that I want you to really stop and
take a look at your life take an honest
look at your life I was thinking just
before I start to make this we have
actually been conditioned to kid with
ourselves to lie to ourselves to not
really take on the honest look at the
results we're getting I want you to take
a real honest look at your results and
when you look at them ask yourself am i
living the way I really want to live you
see most people aren't one of the first
questions I ask a person that comes to
work with me I want to know what's the
most they've ever earned in a year now I
really don't care what the answer is but
I want to know what the answer is
because you see if if a person says the
most I've ever earned in years $50,000 I
know where their mind is programmed and
if they tell me the most I've ever
earned is two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars I know where they're programmed
and then I want to find out what they
want and I know then what has to shift
because their mind is programmed and if
they're really going to live the way
they want to live they they've got to
change the program and if they don't
change the program then nothing really
happens do you know that the law of
attraction is always working it's like
the law of gravity if I let this go it's
going to go down it's never going to go
back up it's going to go down that is
the law of gravity anything heavier
north is attracted towards the center of
the world well the law of attractions
always working now how does it work well
I use a diagram to explain the mind
I'll let this circle represent your MA
and let this little circle here
represent your body now I want you to
think of this for a moment your body is
a molecular structure this is a massive
energy and a very high speed of
vibration if you looked at your body
through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it
the body does not stop moving if you go
to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust you move into
your body and you will move up and it's
how you use your mind that's going to
dictate the vibration you're in now stay
with me you have an imaginary line right
across here and that separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind now the subconscious mind has been
programmed when you were a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there and all the energy
that went in there when you're just a
little baby form something called a
paradigm now a paradigm is information
it's a multitude of habits you are the
product of your environment but prior to
that you are the product of a genetic
strain that goes back four generations
now I'm going to say that the paradigm
is X type energy now you've got the
ability here on a conscious level to
think and you can think anything you
want to think and as you think you build
ideas there's a power that's flowing
into your consciousness it never stops
it flows to and through you you can
actually photograph this power leaving
you it flows to and through you now as
it flows in you will start thinking and
you'll probably think X Y plus therefore
you're going to be in an X type
vibration
and that will produce X tape results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract to see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rest we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
bodies in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you
you see everything operates on
frequencies there's an infinite number
of frequencies but you and I operate on
a frequency just like a radio station
does and the only music you can attract
is the music that is tuned in to the
vibration you're in now it's the
paradigm that has been controlling the
vibration you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you really
change the paradigm and if you don't
change the paradigm nothing happens now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the paradigm that's
causing the problem
you can think a Y type thought which is
totally different than the X type
conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere because when you go to get
emotionally involved and this is the
emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type thought the paradigm will kick it
out you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in then the
vibration area's going to dictate what
you attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why they're done the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen in 1961 a man
gave me this book and he said do exactly
what I tell you he was giving me y-type
ideas it caused an enormous amount of
discomfort but I did exactly what he
said and you know something my income
went from a four thousand a hundred and
seventy five thousand a year and then I
took it over a million it took me nine
and a half years to figure out what
happened this is what I'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here when
the paradigms change your life changes
it's a beautiful concept it's an
absolutely phenomenal concept now you
know why you're getting the results
you're getting it has nothing to do with
your intellect your intellect you can
figure out how to do things that doesn't
mean you're going to do them you'll hear
people say I believe that but their
behavior would indicate they've never
even heard of it why we believe
something on a conscious level on a
subconscious level the paradigm believes
something else there's word called
praxis practices the integration of
belief with behavior we've got to take
the beliefs that we have consciously
that we determined by thinking and plant
them in the place of the old belief see
I used to believe that I couldn't do
anything better than I was doing I felt
fortunate that I was on the fire
department
the idea building a company had operated
all around the world farthest thing from
my mind but you know something as I
changed my paradigm my whole world
changed that's what we do that's what
it's all about you've got to change your
paradigm if you want to change your life
that you can study all you want if you
don't gain an understanding how to alter
that program and that's what the
paradigm is it's a program it's a
multitude of concepts that are fixed in
your subconscious mind that literally
control your behavior it's a beautiful
concept to understand
it's a terrible if you don't understand
it because it literally controls your
life why do you think most people go
right through their life and keep
getting the same results year after year
after year well it's just the way it is
and they don't know we should be taught
this in school but we're not how is the
paradigm form through the repetition of
information how's the paradigm change
repetition of information now let's
suppose you're having a difficult time
with money you find that you got more
going up and coming in you've got to
change your concept about money how do
you do that through the repetition of an
idea that's where affirmations comes in
I'll give you one I've been using for
years I am so happy and grateful now
that money comes to me in increasing
quantities through multiple sources on a
continuous basis I am so happy and
grateful now that money comes to me in
increasing quantities through multiple
sources on a continuous basis you don't
just say that once or twice you've got
to repeat that maybe a thousand times a
day every day for maybe 90 days and
you'll start to change your whole
concept about money wealthy people all
have multiple sources of income now I'm
going to tell you what happened to me I
drove around with a battery-operated
record player and a long playing record
and I played it over and over again
every day for probably a couple of years
this was so totally illogical it was
behavior everybody thought I was losing
it and I'm reading the same book every
day think & Grow Rich as a matter of
fact I'm still reading the same book and
it was the repetition of hurling kills
information and the book that changed
the paradigm I didn't know what I was
doing I didn't understand what I was
doing but I did it do you know I had a
man come up to me in the Waldorf Hotel
in New York the world over story
at the end of a three day program and he
said Baba I really want to thank you for
what you've just given to me he said for
the first time in my life I've
understood how I accomplished what I did
I said what did you do he said I won the
gold medal in the decathlon in the
Olympics in Melbourne Australia in 1957
that's right
Milt Campbell and he said I never
understood how he did it he said the
next time you run a seminar I want to
bring my boys and he did Milton I became
great friends fact Milt is a key to our
house income stay there anytime he wants
I live in Toronto he's in New Jersey but
here was the top athlete the world a
very best athlete in the world
he didn't understand how he got there
most people that are a very accomplished
cannot tell you why they are that's why
they are they've rewritten the program
they changed the paradigm they might not
have understand how they did it but they
did it that's what our company is all
about we teach people how to change
paradigms I want to thank you for
watching this but I'm going to ask you
to share it with other people share with
them say come and watch this start a
rapport build a rapport with people you
know it's a great way to live and this
is great information to understand
thanks for listening
Bob Proctor I enjoy sharing it with
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of the video what did you
think about Bob's message what impact is
it going to have what changes are you
going to make in your life or your
business after watching this what was
your favorite clip leave all of that
somewhere in the comments below I'm
super curious to find out and we'll join
in the discussion I also want to give a
quick shadow to ed edd thank you so much
for picking up a cup of my book thank
you for posting on Facebook I really
appreciate it I hope you enjoy the read
and find your one word so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon